es regnete asche zentimeterdick liegt
hier auf den bananenblättern es ist eine
erte die schmutzig macht bei jeder
kleinsten bewegung
franziskus kleine plantage ist von der
lava verschont worden doch ein großteil
seiner bananen ist verdorben die asche
dringt selbst hilft die schützenden
plastiksäcke
im moment ist die insel schwarz du
siehst von hier nach dort und das ist
schwarz und schwarz wird unsere zukunft
sein
der bananen anbau ist neben dem
tourismus einer der wichtigsten
wirtschaftszweige der insel der vulkan
seine lover seiner asche haben großen
schaden angerichtet die produktion ist
um die hälfte eingebrochen
keiner weiß ob und wie es weitergeht
wir brauchen hilfe wir sind alle
betroffen alle sind in großer not viele
haben ihre fincas und häuser verlassen
mit der asche die der vulkan tag für tag
spuckt kämpfen auch joachim rüppel genug
wenigstens sagen sie sei das
nervenzehrende grollen des vulkans in
letzter zeit ein bisschen leiser
geworden
bombastisch als
währenddessen jäger unterwegs und
einfach explosionen und und grund
geräusch einfach auch immer das gekommen
die beiden mussten vor dem vulkan
fliehen ihr haus steht in der
gefahrenzone jetzt wohnen sie in einem
appartement immerhin ein dachdecker
für zwei personen ist es eng aber wir
haben ja noch glück wir haben hier das
appartement unsere finger steht noch
also wir haben noch dürfen uns gar nicht
beschweren im moment es war ihr kleines
paradies
die finger und der biogarten die lava
kam zwar nicht aber jetzt hat die asche
fast alles begraben
[Musik]
die riesige dunkle rauchwolke ist zum
erkennungszeichen von la palma geworden
seit mehr als sieben wochen spielt der
vulkan feuersteine auch
ununterbrochen wälzt sich die lava
talabwärts sie hat und 2000 häuser
verschluckt jetzt türmt sie sich auf der
vorhandenen schicht auf es sind
mittlerweile zehn ströme einer von ihnen
ergibt sich seit ein paar wochen ins
meer eine neue landzunge ist entstanden
im krisenzentrum der militärischen
spezialeinheit zeigt uns ein hauptmann
diese bilder ein weiterer lavastrom hat
den strand erreicht
heute morgen gab es eine signifikante
veränderung die da war ist dieser
steilküste herunter geflossen wir
beobachten jetzt mit der wärmebildkamera
was sich dort tut
wir wollen nachts erkannte doch
plötzlich geht es für uns nicht weiter
die straße ist gesperrt dahinter liegt
die evakuierte zone rein darf nur wer
dort ein haus oder eine plantage hat auf
solche kontrollpunkte stoßen wir immer
wieder es gibt dutzende rund um den
vulkan auch die codes wollen in die
gefahrenzone zu ihrem haus und nach dem
rechten schauen im kofferraum große
kanister die sie an einer quelle
auffüllen zu
fuß unterbrochen durch den ara strom
sind die wasserleitungen beschädigt
worden und wir brauchen das wasser für
unsere pflanzen zwei endlos lange
stunden müssen sie fahren weil der
direkte weg zur finca von der lava
blockiert ist am kontrollpunkt dann die
enttäuschung heute darf keiner durch
warum wissen sie noch nicht und auch
darauf an wie die wolke ist wieder
friedlich sie kehren um schweren herzens
und in sorge um ihr zuhause
7000 menschen mussten oft überstürzt
ihre häuser verlassen weil die lava kam
zurück blieben viele tiere katzen hunde
in sichtweite des vulkans auf dem
sportplatz einer schule haben einige von
ihnen vorübergehend schutz gefunden
immer wieder bringen helfer verstörte
tiere aus der gefahrenzone hierher
[Musik]
miriam bartolini und ihr mann holger
wollen helfen gassi gehen mit und rufus
wurde von seinem besitzer hierher
gebracht weil er dort wo er jetzt
untergekommen ist keine tiere halten
darf wir versuchen gerade zu helfen
jeder auf seine weise und uns lag
tierschutz immer schon am herzen auch
miriam und holger haben ein trauma durch
liegt ihr haus wurde von der lava
verschluckt einen monat ist das jetzt
her
[Musik]
aber immerhin haben darüber den kopf wir
konnten unsere nötigsten sachen holen
fast keine möbel also da sind halt auch
springe von meinen großeltern dritten
diesen 200 jahre alt gewesen jetzt nicht
mehr und das ist natürlich auch nicht
wiederbringen wären es normale zeiten
dann wären die cafés in den malerischen
orten rund um den vulkan voller
touristen doch es herrscht gähnende
leere die inselregierung wirkt jetzt
aktiv um tagesbesucher und damit dass
die hälfte der einnahmen an die
betroffenen fließt
wir ermutigen die menschen uns zu
besuchen damit der tourismus wieder
anläuft
wir haben sehr viele stornierungen auch
die lokalen veranstalter live es muss
uns gelingen diesen sektor wieder zum
laufen zu bringen
und es scheint zu funktionieren
viele urlauber kommen von der
nachbarinsel teneriffa um den vulkan zu
sehen
ich kann mir nur vorstellen wie hilft
dass ich die leute fehlen man hat wenn
man die maske abnimmt auch staub im mund
sofort es ist schon sehr sehr
faszinierende heft man muss es selbst
sehen das ist unglaublich zu was die
natur imstande ist und was das bei den
leuten hier anrichtet
[Musik]
er ist faszinierend und gleichzeitig
furchteinflößend schon jetzt hat der
vulkan la palma für immer verändert und
keiner weiß wann er zur ruhe kommt
[Musik]